bushes
here one on the other side of the tree
not this
fall but last fall now one was a full
Bush and everyone was a dormant start
from Tractor Supply so we had one this
was the start here and then the other
one was a full on Bush now this is an
invasive monovic this is a non-invasive
type of Wisteria which here in the South
with Syria can be very invasive you'll
see it all over the highways climbing
through trees my mom has it in her
backyard her house is over 100 years old
and she has
what appears to be beautiful beautiful
Wisteria Vines but they will take over
your trees if they can jump onto your
house they will take over your house
anything they could climb on they will
take over and they can really choke out
a lot of ecosystems that you don't want
them to and that is the main problem
with invasive things is when they grow
places you don't want them to yeah my
non-invasive Vines
will not do that they will stay where
you put them you can cut them back they
will grow where you want Instagram which
is excellent unfortunately
the difference is that
you do have to help them to climb now
once they are truly truly truly
established they will start to find a
little
bit
we're going to climb up in the tree a
little bit
um now I bought mine from a nursery here
in town and they told me all the
differences between the invasive and the
non-invasive I did a whole video on this
I will link it down below um but again
the main difference is you have to help
it climb until it gets truly established
and that can take a couple years so
these whips that are coming off of those
branches off of line here
they need help climbing the tricks they
can't really do it on their own you can
see that they are
Outlets
along the ground I will do it a clip
right here to show you it goes all the
way over there's a really really long
lip on the other side of the tree going
along the ground by the garden so all of
those will help going around the tree
it's a little funny but they grow really
fast this is one Summer's worth of grow
th
these are still fairly blue Vines I've
only got one season of wounds out of
them this year and that one season was
about five to ten rooms
um the the ones at the nursery were
beautiful they had hundreds of ones so
maybe next year it's grown so much this
year it's grown you know almost 10 times
more than it grew last week at this
season so today all we're going to be
doing is taking these
little u-shaped snails do you change
nails and we're going to be helping to
attack the vine in place up around the
tree so that it can grow now the whole
reason I am growing these now
on this tree is that history
is a
is not doing supervised it's probably
not going to make it forever I'm not
going to get this
however
this is a big experiment when I move out
of this house I will be taking house
with needs a modular house but when I
move this tree will probably come down
and so the whole idea of this is to try
it out see our non-invasive lines
ever house we plant them somewhere where
they become an issue so for today
I'm going to take our Hammer to go take
your nails and help guide these lines up
around the tree and if you have a tree
that is super important to you and is
not as sure
a lot of your sturdier trees will take
Nails in the bar some kids
so if you make sure you
can ask at your Nursery look for someone
to ask and your teacher
try um you know wrote me twine around
the branches to help keep guiding them
upwards and giving them a growing
support until they can reach something
up top to Anchor them into the tree
something that's a lot less detrimental
than that
that I'm not worried about we're using
Nails I've been doing this for almost
two years now and we have had no issues
but we are getting to the point where we
really need a top where I can't reach
and so on in the driveway now is my tall
brother
we've got a top brother and a tall
ladder we're gonna get this guy taken
care of so let's get started
gonna be a lot of me stretching divides
of him putting the nails on
all right so you're gonna place it right
over the Vine
yeah and you'll hammer it in just until
it is really in the bark
when you can you want to leave enough
room for the vine to still kind of move
around and grow
and that's it just keep on
pulling them up the tree
[Music]
foreign
all right we got everything put up the
tree my phone overheated so I don't know
how much of it y'all saw
but we've got the big whip put up you
can see it up at the top it went all the
way to the top of the tree
and all the little ones are woven in now
I try to weave them so that the leaves
are
front face out because they grow with
front face out but you can see
will doesn't know that so he just puts
him up so he's got some back face ones
but
it's okay they go all the way up
oh that one probably could have been
tacked better you can see the end there
but you know what it's fine
and instead of literally the one whip we
had around at the beginning of the
Season we have a whole trunk full
and I'm really hoping that means next
year we will have a whole tree of blooms
this is time when buying an invasive
Vine that would climb on its own sounds
really good but for the two years it's
been installed that I've had it planted
I'm falling over I only had to do this
two three times now obviously you saw
the whips I should have done this at
least two times this season and I
haven't so that's part of it
um but
lots of growth this year so I'm calling
that a win
I'm gonna go inside and get cool because
it's hot hot out here my brother has
already left he has
he has finished his uh brotherly Duty
for the day
I will see y'all in the next project
bye stay cool